[Music]
what is value lock-in and could you give
some historical examples
so value lock-in is when a single
ideology or value system or kind of set
of ideologies
kind of takes control of an area or in
the limit the whole world and then
persists for an extremely long time
and
this is one thing that i think can have
very very long lasting effects and we've
already seen it throughout history and
so in the
in what we are the future i give a story
of ancient china
so
during this period that's known as the
hundred schools of thought the zhu
dynasty had fallen and there was like a
lot of fragmentation like ideological
fragmentation in china and wandering
philosophers would go from state to
state with a package of kind of
philosophical ideas and moral views and
political policy recommendations and
trying to convince like political elites
of their ideas
and there were four main schools
there were the confucians that we're
kind of most familiar with
the legalists which are kind of like
machiavellian like political realists
um just you know how do you get power
was the main focus of them
taoists who are these kind of
more
somewhat more spiritual like acting in
accordance with the way with nature like
advocating spontaneity honesty
and then finally the moists which i read
and i'm like wow they were kind of
similar to the effect of like effective
altitudes except in ancient china
where they were about promoting good
outcomes and good outcomes impartially
considered
they
forwent
much like fancy kind of spending on
luxury or ritual so their funeral lights
were very
modest they wore very modest clothes
and they were just really concerned
about trying to make the world better
and so they created a power military
group in order to defend cities that
were under siege
where the reasoning being that if
defensive technology and defensive
strategy was so good
then no one could ever wage a war
because no one could ever win
and so there was this great diversity of
thought but what happened one state
within china the chin
influenced by legalism took over
and tried to
try to essentially make
legalism
state orthodoxy and the emperor chin
declared himself a ten thousand year
emperor wanted this ideology to persist
indefinitely it actually only lasted 14
years because there was a kind of
counter rebellion and that was the start
of the han dynasty
which then successfully did
basically over the course of
a while
quell kind of other ideological
competition and instead
implemented confucianisms like this is
the official state ideology and that
persisted for 2000 years
and
that's kind of just one example among
many
over and over again you see
what's the kind of ideology or belief
set of a ruling power whether that's
christians or certainly i mean catholics
or protestants or is it communism of the
khmer rouge of stalin or national
socialism of hitler
once that ideology gets into power
people with his ideology get into power
they quickly try and stomp out the
competition
and the worry is that could happen with
the entire world so again i spoke of a
risk of third world war
well what might happen as a result one
ideology could
take power globally after winning such a
war
implement a world
government or world state or at least
dominant world ideology
then we're in this situation where
there's much less ideological
competition
and at least one reason why we've gotten
moral change in model progress over time
which is in virtue of having a diversity
of moral views that are able to like
kind of fight it out in the in ideal
circumstances the kind of the best
argument wins we would no longer have
that and so
if there was a single kind of dominant
ideology in the world that could persist
for an extremely long time i think
and if it was wrong which is quite
likely to be wrong because i think most
of our moral views are probably wrong
that would be like very bad indeed
yeah
i mean just to give you an idea i mean
this is not exactly ideological but you
mentioned the han
dynasty
and
in mandarin chinese one way to say
mandarin chinese is kanye which is
the language of the han people like like
is the romanization
system used which most people have seen
with the diacritical marks for tones for
mandarin chinese so these things can
last a very long time indeed do you have
any other examples of
a value
lock-in that could be past tense
historical examples or attempts that are
being made currently that you think are
worth
making mention of could be either i mean
historically one particularly salient
example was uh when the khmer rouge took
power in cambodia paul pott just very
systematically like anyone who disagreed
with the kind of party ideology
would be
i mean generally would just be executed
so 25 percent of the population were
killed in cambodia and i mean he again
it's like
very transparent what's happening he has
this quote purify the party purify the
army purify the catholics so it's just
very clear that's what going on is you
know almost like a
species or virus kind of taking over and
like other
competitors get wiped out this one
ideology takes over competitors are
wiped out
similarly if we look at like british
history
with
at different times catholics and
protestants taking power there was one
act passed
called the act of uniformity
with
the
protestants saying like okay catholicism
is now banned in this country and again
it's like very boldly named and in
general just if you have a particular
moral view then
you are going to want everyone else in
the world to have that particular model
view as well
you